what up space fam Goldson here from
anime upper and I'm back at it again
with a new one piece video about the
Blackbeard Pirates the crew that the
straw hats have to watch out for more
than any other we got a lot of important
information that came out about them
recently in the manga so it seems like a
great time to do this so make sure to
stay tuned for that if you do enjoy
these longer one piece videos I want to
keep them coming you know what to do
Channel parking with it and smash that
like button until you set off the
YouTube fireworks via smashing Power
King rather than passing Orochi and the
universe will reward you make this the
day you join the knock one by
subscribing and hitting that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one piece videos and updates and now
without further Ado let's jump into It
spoilers and all we'll start with the 10
Titanic captains of the Blackbeard
Pirates number one Jesus Burgess is the
Helmsman of the Blackbeard Pirates and
the captain of the first ship he's also
known as the champion he's currently 29
years old he was first introduced to us
back during chapter 222 when he just
beat up another pirate called him a
weakling and laughed he referred
referred to himself as the champion
Grappler he's one of those strong
characters that's always looking for a
good challenge even before getting his
devil fruit he was strong he lifted and
threw a hotel at Ace before Blackbeard
told him he should stay out of the fight
because he's not up to Ace's level Post
Time skip Burgess was defeated by Sabo
who used his newly eaten flame flame
fruit to ruthlessly attack Burgess it
didn't help Burgess that he kept mocking
Sabo for not being there to save his
brother Ace still despite Sabo getting
the better of him and hurting him really
bad Burgess ends up recovering and is
currently in perfect shape from the
looks of it he even got revenge against
Sabo in a way by helping the Blackbeard
Pirates to find the Revolutionary Army's
Main Headquarters they destroyed the
island but the Revolutionary Army
managed to escape we've recently found
out that Burgess has gotten an even
better fruit for his character than the
flame flame fruit he's consumed the
rikiriki no me aka the strong strong
fruit as law noted it gives him super
strength which is a big deal in a world
where people without this fruit can
already lift stuff like hotels whereas
we saw pre-time skip Burgess left the
hotel before the ace fight we now see
this new bird just lift a mountain to
the shock of the heart Pirates he then
throws a mountain at the crew pretty
crazy stuff it would be surprising at
this point if Burgess isn't the
physically strongest character in the
series aka the one that can lift the
most weight because otherwise what would
even be the point of the fruit and we
know that Blackbeard only wants the best
of the best fruit so this one has to be
a good one number two is the 44 year old
shiru of the rain the captain of the
second ship he used to be the head
Jailer of impel down and ivankov called
him as powerful as Warden Magellan
ivankov even said that he may have been
more deadly than Magellan due to word
and Magellan's relative lack of
experience because he was so dangerous
brutal and massacred prisoners on a whim
he was imprisoned on level 6. he was
released to help quell the prison riots
but then joined the Blackbeard Pirates
instead and yeah can't say I didn't see
that coming you can't really expect the
guy you imprisoned to be loyal to when
released shiryu was also given back his
Mato AKA special named blade Ryu he
showed his swordsmanship skills when he
quickly took out the jailers that
released him shiru also saved the
Blackbeard Pirates by giving them the
antidote to Magellan's poisoning later
Post Time skip we find out that the
Blackbeard Pirates took absalom's clear
clear fruit and now shiryu has it he
used it to turn invisible sneak up on
Moria and then cut him most recently we
haven't seen shiru at the heart Pirates
vs Blackbeard Pirates fight yet but that
just means the Blackbeard Pirates have
another Ace in the Hole and he could
potentially pop up anytime if needed
number three is the 27 year old van
auger nicknamed the supersonic he's a
sniper and the captain of the third ship
he debuted during chapter 222 as we saw
him shooting down seagulls from a very
far distance to further praise His
sniping ability Nami was saying to
Chopper it's impossible that someone was
shooting from an island that they
couldn't even see even usoper's sniper
was saying and I quote how could anyone
see so far and what kind of gun could
shoot all this way what's sniper could
do that they were probably shot
somewhere else and just happened to fall
here end quote so big sniping praise for
Van auger right off the bat who did in
fact take the lives of those seagulls
instantly except for one when Ace
appears before the Blackbeard Pirates
later then auger interrupts Ace's words
by firing some bullets at him but
because Ace just turns to fire they pass
right through him Ace shoots some fire
bullets back which auger manages to
dodge this is when Blackbeard tells him
along with Burgess that they aren't on
Ace's level yet and they should stay out
of this fight obviously we know what
happened at Marine Ford and auger along
with the other Blackbeard Pirates helped
finish off an injured Whitebeard after
Marine Ford auger using his insane
ability to see across long distances is
the one that notices that Akainu is on
the approaching Marine ship as a result
Blackbeard realizes that the Marines are
not planning to trade a warship for
jewelry body thus the Blackbeard Pirates
choose to leave since Blackbeard says
he's not ready to take on Akainu yet we
saw recently that post time skip auger
along with kuzan helped kidnap pudding
from the big mom Pirates he was then
seen fighting along with other
Blackbeard forces against the heart
Pirates he's been showcasing his new
warp War fruit ability that lets him
teleport himself and others to different
locations we don't know the exact
limitations of the fruit yet for
instance we don't know the limit to how
far auger could teleport himself and
others but if it's related to his
abilities chances are he can teleport at
least as far as he can see and since he
can see so exceptionally far chances are
it's the perfect ability for him number
four is the 42 year old avalo Pizarro
also known as the corrupt King he is one
of the oh so dangerous level 6 prisoners
from impal down he used to be the king
of a North Blue Kingdom before he was
overthrown due to his tyrannical ways he
is currently the captain of the fourth
ship we haven't seen a lot from mabalo
yet but we can assume he's very strong
not only because he was a level 6
prisoner but also because he's one of
the ones who survived after Blackbeard
pitted the level 6 prisoners against
each other thus he's one of the most
dangerous even among the most dangerous
again he hasn't appeared yet in the
fight against the hard Pirates which
just further reinforces that the hard
Pirates are in big trouble since all of
these strong Blackbeard Pirates may
still appear especially if they are
truly needed notably the corrupt King
wasn't wearing a striped prisoner's
uniform at the time of his debut while
the other level 6 prisoners like Vasco
Devin and San Juan wolf were number five
is the 41 year old Lafitte nicknamed The
Demon Sheriff he's the Navigator chief
of staff and captain of the fifth ship
his story is a bit similar to shirus
Lafitte was a former sheriff in the West
Blue but was banished because of his
brutality Lafitte debuted during a
warlord meeting which was impressive
because he seemed to sneak in without
being noticed even though a lot of
high-level people were there like
sengoku since crocodile is no longer a
warlord at this point Lafitte comes to
recommend someone to be his replacement
and as we know that someone ends up
being Blackbeard from a river card it
was revealed that his Bounty at one
point was 42.2 Million berries but that
all but certainly grew since then he has
interesting and useful power so you can
hypnotize people and did that during the
Marine Ford Arc so that the victims
would let any warships close to the
gates of Justice pass another impressive
aspect is that he's able to get to such
secure places like the Marines control
room and into the meeting with the
Warlords and sengoku without being
noticed it suggests he's really good at
avoiding being sensed even around people
who should have high level sensory
hockey we don't know much about his
powers beyond that we have seen him use
angel-like white wings to fly which is
likely a clue to what his devil fruit is
but the power hasn't been confirmed yet
he also likes to use a pistol as we saw
when he helps other Blackbeard Pirates
finish off Whitebeard and of course he
carries around a cane which can
potentially be used as a weapon as well
there are clearly implicationally strong
since hisayanko Commander he threatens
to kill strong level 6 prisoners like
avalo Pizarro and he potentially has a
zone or even mythical Zone devil fruit
as the white Wings imply thus although
the information on him leaves much to be
desired it also serves to Hype his
character and build up the anticipation
for when he gets involved in a big fight
the commander of the sixth ship is none
other than the 36 year old Katarina
Devon aka the Crescent Moon Hunter this
lady is 11 feet and 10 inches tall she
debuted during chapter 575 as one of the
strongest of the strong level 6
prisoners that joined the crew she does
not shoot at Whitebeard like many do but
seemingly uses a spear as the crew
attacks Whitebeard together it truly
wouldn't be surprising if Lafitte ended
up having a mythical Zone since we
already have multiple confirmed mythical
zones on the crew and Devin is one of
them she has the Inu Inu no meme model
QB no Kitsune aka the dog dog fruit
model nine-tailed fox this fruit is
similar to the Clone clone fruit but
Superior as mythical Zone fruits tend to
be not only can she turn into a
nine-tailed fox she could also transform
into clones of other people and unlike
the Clone clone fruit she can change the
clothing too so even though cloning is
just one of the confirmed powers of this
fruit it already does it better than the
paramecia Clone clone fruit another
ability of course is the ability to
transform into a nine-tailed fox
although we haven't seen that form being
especially useful yet Devin is one of
the commanders along with vasco's shot
that accompanies Blackberry to Amazon
Lily where the latter confronts boa and
tries to steal her devil fruit we see
some of her Ward personality when she
says she'd love to have Hancock's
beautiful face as a detached head that
she'd treasure Blackbeard is even cool
with it as long as he gets bola's power
however we don't get to see much action
from Devin before she gets turned to
stone by bullet's power she may have
remained a stone statue if Rayleigh
didn't show up and de-escalate the
situation between Blackbeard and boa
next we have San Juan wolf a level 6
prisoner and a giant of a giant ivankov
singles great Battleship San Juan wolf
out along with Devin and Vasco shot as
being one of the worst prisoners in
impel down and as a pirate who shook the
world he is currently the captain of the
seventh ship of the Blackbeard Pirates
it's also known worthy that wolf is 99
years old and 180 meters tall which is
about the height of the Space Needle in
Seattle he debuts in chapter 575 as he
pokes his head out from behind find the
Marine Ford Fortress giving a sense of
how unbelievably big he is and why he a
person is referred to as a great
Battleship or a colossal Battleship
furthermore in the following chapters
commented there's only one creature that
big meaning wolf is known to Tower above
all others in size we haven't seen much
of his powers but we can assume that his
strength and destructive power is
reflected in his giant size after all he
was deemed dangerous enough to be a
level 6 prisoner in his Vibra card it's
also revealed that he ate a paramecia
type devil fruit an unnamed one that
makes him so much bigger than even other
Giants even though the sea is usually
deadly for fruit users wolf is seen
being tall enough to stand in the ocean
as we see during chapter 595 even though
he can breathe and talk with his head
sticking out of the water like this he
does still whine about feeling weak
which must be the true user weakness of
the sea acting on him although it's
clearly not as dangerous for him as it
would be for Less tall people next up we
have another level 6 prisoner mentioned
by ivankov Vasco shot the heavy drinker
he is the Titanic captain of the eighth
ship he's 38 years old and 18 feet and
10 inches tall so very tall if you think
about it the only issue is that nothing
seems that tall after Wolf's height
reveal Vasco shot is fittingly one of
the ones who shoots a pistol at
Whitebeard when the crew is attacking
him as usual not much is known about his
fighting skills as the case with most
Titanic captains he has good endurance
and could bounce back from attacks by
Whitebeard and sengoku chances are he
has already gotten or will get an OP
devil fruit like the others but it
hasn't been revealed yet he was as
mentioned there with Blackbeard and
Devin when they attacked boa while the
latter two were cool with deleting her
existence Vasco thought it would be more
fun to take her alive and be quote
unquote good friends with her end quote
but again as with Devin his presence was
kind of underwhelming here because we
didn't see any real Combat from him but
just jumps to him being a frozen Stone
statue thanks to rayleigh's intervention
he was turned back to normal like Devin
although obviously it makes more sense
for auger the sniper to fight usop at
the end but again it would be fun to see
vasque when usop interact because
according to Oda Vasco has the longest
nose out of any character that's been
introduced so far if these two were to
fight or just interact at some point you
know their no sizes will be brought up
next we have docq aka the death God
ironically even though he's a doctor of
the Blackbeard Pirates he's actually
quite the sickly guy during his intro he
says he was born with a weak
Constitution Luffy and Zoro actually
help him get from off the ground back on
his horse stronger since docu needs
stronger to get around however stronger
the horse is quite sickly too as we'll
get into when we discuss him dot Q
actually pretends to thank our guys by
offering them some apples from his
basket Luffy actually tries one while
Zoro rationally refuses commenting on
how suspicious they look it is only
after Luffy swallows the Apple that they
find out some of the apples have been
exploding however as doc Q points out
Luffy didn't grab one of those or else
he would have been done already he
comments on Luffy being a lucky boy I
definitely suspected that he'd be older
but in reality the always sick.q is only
28 years old after the time Skip and
despite being that young he is the
captain of the ninth ship of the
Blackbeard Pirates as with most doctors
he can obviously heal and Burgess
specifically asked for him when he
suffered massive damage thanks to Sabo
and the flame flame fruit however as we
saw you can also make non-explosive
things explosive and deadly as he did
with the apples he is also known for
using a scythe like the Grim Reaper and
used it to attack Whitebeard with the
other Blackbeard Pirates so obviously
can engage in combat when necessary he
ate the sick sick fruit which allows him
to give illnesses to others he used this
ability against law and his crew
specifically he used the feminization
disease to humorous effect but also to
create confusion among lost crew now
high level hockey control can still
counter the effect of the fruit but you
can just imagine how much large-scale
damage such a power could cause in the
world and I'm sure a lot of the diseases
are much more dangerous than the
feminization disease that he used
against law and his crew and again
during the hard Pirates battle docu used
explosive Apple however they weren't
that effective in combat so far and of
course since they are so tied together
let's just discuss docu's horse stronger
right here stronger is another member of
the Blackbeard Pirates the 10th one we
discussed so far stronger is just as
sick as doc Q despite supporting the
latter so the two make quite the
humorous duel and because Blackbeard is
so focused on Gathering the best devil
fruits it makes sense that even docu's
Horrors has a pretty epic devil fruit
specifically he has the horse horse
fruit model Pegasus which allows him to
fly we see him carrying both daku and
black bear through the air during the
fight against the hard Pirates although
he was definitely struggling under
Blackbeard's added weight and since
there are 10 Titanic commanders but we
only discussed 9 so far since stronger
than one of them we still have a mystery
commander of the 10th ship now with
speculation who this could be but we do
know that another member of the
Blackbeard Pirates is former Admiral
kuzan who is easily strong and deserving
enough to be a Titanic captain to me one
of the craziest aspects of the
Blackbeard Pirates is still that they
managed to get this Legend to join them
a dude who was nominated by send Goku to
be Fleet Admiral now there are theories
that he could be undercover working with
sword but since that is only a theory
we're going to be treating kuzan as a
full member of the Blackbeard Pirates
and an asset to their overall power and
as we saw recently he does help them get
things done for example he went with
auger to steal putting and made it look
easy as he left everything Frozen
including yaku Commander Charlotte
cracker he hasn't even shown up to some
important battles like the one with boa
and the one with law yet but chances are
that that's because Blackbeard felt like
he could have handled those situations
without him so far although kuzan may
still appear during the battle against
the hard Pirates you never know
especially since auger and putting are
there kuzan is currently 49 years old
meaning he's 9 years older than
Blackbeard himself most of us know he
has the logia Isis fruit which allows
him to freeze Landscapes and opponents
it allows him to turn water beneath him
to ice so that the ocean is practically
a non-issue to him and on a side note
such a power would massively trouble the
hard Pirates Who are specifically strong
in the sea my my favorite aspect of his
powers is that they let him bike over
the sea as a mode of transportation
obviously kuza can also turn himself
into ice whenever he deems it useful
kuzan and his fruit powers are so strong
that he was able to fight the current
Fleet Admiral sakazuki for 10 days and
their clashing fruits permanently
changed the climate of punk Hazard so
that the island is now divided into a
sea of fire on one side and icebergs on
the other ultimately it looks like kuzan
Was Defeated and then he resigned from
the Marines and eventually joined the
Blackbeard Pirates now the fact that
sakazuki spared his life could mean that
they got some agreement about him acting
on his own but still with akazuki's
secret approval but that's just
speculation at this point let me know
your thoughts on kuzan and where you
think his allegiances lie I mean it is
pretty suspect that the Admiral who was
arguably the most moral is working for
Blackbeard but at the same time I almost
feel like it would be too predictable
now for kuzan to be working for sword
and it would undermine the power of the
Blackbeard Pirates which would make
their final conflict with the straw hats
less intense then there are some less
well-known like we're Pirates like
kikipatsu kikipatsu was there sitting
close to Blackbeard drinking and
laughing while the latter was speaking
to Gekko Moria in a Vibra card his name
was revealed and it was noted that he
loves Plum beer and his nose turns red
when he drinks it it's pretty
interesting they can be so Carefree in
Blackbeard's presence then there's Maki
a woman with purple hair and an orange
cowboy hat that was cozying up to
Blackbeard as kikipatsu was laughing in
a river card it was revealed that she
was amused by Gekko moria's fight with
her crew members and her name when
combined with Tori who we're about to
look into next is a potential pun for
Tori Maki meaning Entourage which seems
pretty fitting so far Tori is the other
woman that was cozying up to Blackbird
at the time she's blonde and wears a
white dress she clearly likes to drink
since she has a bottle in both hands but
we're told she has a high level of
Tolerance and so unlike kikipatsu her
complexion doesn't change so who knows
how relevant these three members will be
later on but Oda chose to put them close
to Blackbeard and then to talk about
them more in a river card so they could
have end up being more relevant than
we'd at first suspect now aside from
Blackberry the most interesting one and
the one we'll get into soon those are
all of the official members of the
Blackbeard Pirates including Blackbeard
and the unknown 10th Commander that's 16
known members but we also know that the
peach beard Pirates had Affiliated
themselves with the Blackbeard Pirates
as a subordinate crew Peach beard had a
52 million Berry Bounty however he was
taken out pretty easily by some
revolutionary Army commanders and the
townspeople of the Lucia who were pumped
up by Bello Betty's Pom-Pom fruit power
it's now worthy to point out that the
main ship of the Blackbeard Pirates is
called the Sabra zebic of course Rock
Steve's epic was the Legendary Pirate
captain of The Rock's Pirates a crew
that included many legendary Pirates
including Whitebeard big mom and kaido
tame a few it seems Blackbeard wants to
follow in his example and create a crew
using the strongest people and also in
his case fruit powers that he can find
so now it's time to turn to Captain
himself Blackbeard it is important to
note here that Oda has stated that
Blackbeard is his favorite historical
pirate as a result you can that
Blackbeard is going to get very special
treatment in the story he already has
but that will continue no doubt Janko
Blackbeard AKA Marshall D teach is
currently 40 years old a year older than
fellow yonko Shanks and has the second
highest Bounty of any current Yoko at
3.996 billion berries he's only behind
Shanks who is slightly ahead at 4.0489
billion put another way Shanks is only
52.9 million ahead and I have a feeling
blackbeards will surpass shanks's real
soon especially considering that he had
this bounty before he attacked Bola
kidnapped Kobe and then attacked law
Blackbeard has always been special even
before he got his op Del through Powers
even back when whitebeard's crew used to
clash with Roger's crew a young black
beer will singled out kid buggy talks
about how they say Blackbeard never
slept in his life and he calls him a
monster ironically Shanks wasn't too
phased by him at this point even though
he'd go on to warn others like
Whitebeard about how dangerous
Blackbeard is down the line notably at
some point more than 12 years ago
Blackbeard gave Shanks the three scars
he has over his eye and Shanks
emphasized that it wasn't because he was
careless rather Blackbeard was just that
impressive even before any devil fruit
powers and for anyone who says that
Shanks has gotten way stronger since
then I raised you the very real
possibility that Blackbeard has also
improved just as much now we come to
Blackbeard's insane level of patience he
refused the position of second division
commander of the Whitebeard Pirates
saying he did not have that kind of
ambition and people bought it even
though this dude is arguably the most
ambitious guy in the entire Series so
people that say Blackbeard relies too
much on delford Powers are missing the
fact that the dude seems to have vested
Shanks when he gave him the scars and he
was capable of being a yonko commander
before he ever ate a fruit the only
reason he joined the Whitebeard Pirates
is because he thought it was the best
chance of getting the dark dark fruit
and he stayed low-key until thatch found
the fruit and then killed him stole the
fruit and left the crew to start his own
that tells us at least two things that
Blackbeard is crazy patient and that the
dark dark fruit must truly be very
special if someone would go through all
that just to get their hands on it even
early on Blackbeard tells Ace with this
meaning the power of the dark dark fruit
he is the strongest in the world
Blackbeard calls it the most dangerous
power in the history of all devil fruit
Powers no small statement considering
how many epic fruits are out there
Blackbeard goes on to explain that
darkness is gravity a Darkness so dense
it sucks in everything even light
infinite gravity Blackbeard then
proceeds to show off he tells Ace he's
not going to attack him yet and for him
to just watch as he uses his powers to
suck into town he uses the move black
hole and the whole town sinks into the
darkness Blackbeard explains his dark
gravity compresses objects with infinite
power and crushes them then he uses
Liberation releases the destroyed pieces
of the town from his darkness and it's
nothing but scrap wood afterwards when
Ace attacks Blackbeard however he's
surprised at the fact that an apparent
logia doesn't let Blackbeard avoid fire
attacks Blackbeard explains upset that
Darkness sucks in everything whether
it's punches blades bullets fly fire or
lightning his body absorbs pain and that
pain is actually Amplified in the
process but in exchange there's another
thing he can absorb he uses the move
black Vortex and explains that the
gravity of Darkness can pull in the
actual body of devil fruit users Ace is
sucked in until Blackbeard is holding
his shoulder furthermore now that
Blackbeard is holding him Ace can't use
his logia powers Blackbeard punches Ace
and the latter takes the full brunt of
the attack because he can't just turn
into fire and avoid it Blackbeard
further explains that the other thing
his Darkness absorbs is the power of the
devil fruits and jumping forward into
the future my assumption is that this
fruit is also what allows him to extract
other people's fruits like he did with
Whitebeard as we know Blackbeard was
strong enough to beat ace not only that
he succeeded in taking a live Ace
hostage which is harder to do because
you have to make sure during the fight
that you don't accidentally delete your
opponent from existence since Blackbeard
wanted him alive he probably had to hold
back during the fight as well Blackbeard
gave ace to the world government and
then as a warlord answered the call when
the world government gathered the seven
Warlords to help them fight Whitebeard
all this time Blackbeard was
strategizing by becoming a warlord he
gained special access to certain places
and that allowed him to break the
deadliest level 6 prisoners out of impel
down and to recruit them similarly by
handing over Ace through the world
government he guaranteed that Whitebeard
would come and so set the stage for
eventually stealing his Tremor Tremor
fruit which is considered to be the
strongest paramecia when Whitebeard
tries to use his fruit Powers against
Blackbeard Blackbeard initially
nullifies them with his dark dark fruit
however then Whitebeard Cuts him with
his blade and then forms a quick bubble
around his head for maximum damage this
is when Blackbeard tells his crew to get
Whitebeard whitebeard's already injured
at this point but he's still called a
monster because he just refuses to go
down Blackbeard's crew attacks together
as previously mentioned to finish him
off that Blackbeard proceeds to somehow
steal the lay white Beard's devil fruit
power but the whole time it was covered
up so we didn't see how he actually did
it but as mentioned I personally think
it is tied to the dark fruit and it's
part of the reason Blackbeard devoted
his whole life to find it it could even
potentially be the awakened power of the
fruit Blackbird then uses the dark fruit
and the Trevor Tremor fruit together to
people's shock not only does he have two
fruits which is supposed to be
impossible those two fruits are insanely
special one is considered the strongest
pair of Misa can destroy the world and
the other is considered to be the most
dangerous fruit power in History
Blackbeard himself says that I quote
it's the gravity of Darkness that turns
everything into nothingness and the
power of the earthquake that destroys
everything now I have it all I'm
Invincible I'm the greatest end quote
it's even more crazy that he's saying
all this while in the middle of a
star-studded battlefield once again
Blackbeard is singled out for being
special Marco says it's true that normal
humans can't have two different devil
fruit Powers but he says Teach as a
normal his body is odd maybe that
explains it end quote Blackbeard
proclaims that as of today his era
begins Blackbeard calls his new power
exhilarating and causes a lot of insane
tilting of the battlefield but he comes
to the conclusion that he can't control
it too well yet even his own man tells
him not to overdo it or he'll take out
the ground under them as well Blackbeard
is insanely Compton at this point
calling out Buddha sengoku and Hiro Garb
asking if they think they can stop him
he says no one can stop him it's crazy
that all of this is happening pre-time
skip you gotta hand to the Blackbeard it
really seemed like he was right to take
on everyone present until shank shows up
to put a stop to the war Shanks even
calls out tiege asking if he wants to go
but Blackbeard passes saying he got what
he wanted and that this is not yet the
time for him to fight Shanks so this
change in Blackbeard definitely speaks
to the power of Shanks and his crew but
it must be noted that Blackbeard doesn't
look scared he even laughs they all got
the same face here plus Blackbeard got
what he wanted after the war Blackbeard
continues to accumulate feet out their
feet in the new world he beats fellow
worst generation pirate jewelry Bonnie
and her crew he ties her up and implies
she's not strong enough to make it a new
world he even says he doesn't need a
weakling like her on the crew but he'll
take her along if she agrees to be his
woman she of course refuses unlike Maki
and Tori during the time skip while the
straw hats are training Blackbeard
continues to dance in the pirate World a
year after the Paramount War Marco and
the other remnants of the Whitebeard
Pirates Clash would teach and his
Blackbeard pirates in what the world
calls The Grudge War it is quite a large
battle and each side brings in plenty of
help we're told in the end though
Marco's group is obliterated so it
appears to have been a very one-sided
War this really speaks to Blackbeard's
power because even without Whitebeard
marked when the remaining Whitebeard
Pirates and allies should not have been
weak by any measure only after this
major confrontation and smashing Victory
does Blackbeard join the list of yonko
he goes on with his knowledge as a
former Whitebeard Pirates member to
conquer former Whitebeard territories to
expand his crew into a fleet and his old
crew members become the already
explained Titanic captains while
Blackbeard himself becomes the Admiral
we also know that somehow during the
rocky Port incident Kobe helped
Blackbeard topple Ultra Cool AKA Wang ji
a former member of the Rocks Pirates and
that ultimately made Blackbeard the boss
of pirate island during the zorark we
find out that Blackbird actually leveled
the revolution Army's headquarters Luffy
thinks it might be because Sabo fought
with Burgess back in dressrosa it's a
pretty crazy side note in the story and
shows how Blackbeard doesn't even fear
Dragon the so-called world's worst
criminal we then get to the want to Arc
where former warlord gecko Moria
searches for Blackbeard on Pirate Island
he finds out that Blackbeard's shiryu
now has absalom's clear clear fruit
meaning that Absalom is nothing more
than a corpse now Blackbeard then
invites Moria to join his crew thus we
potentially have morya joining
Blackbeard's crew although we won't go
into detail with Moria and his shadow
shadow fruit yet since it's just
speculation at this point however there
is a possibility at least that they
could find kaido after his defeat at
Luffy's hands and finish him off morya
wanted revenge on kaido and a lot of
people speculate that Blackbeard wanted
kaido's mythical Zone fruit if they
ended kaido Blackbeard can take the
fruit and Morey can take the corpse just
speculation but it would definitely make
Blackbeard and Moria happy if things
turned out this way then again
Blackbeard could just take the shadow
shadow fruit powers and give them to
another one of his crew members if he
wanted to during chapter 956 after the
warlord system is disbanded Blackbeard
decides to set sail saying if the Navy
is only going to take it he might as
well claim the prize we later find out
that the prize he had in mind was the
meadow metal no me AK ball as long love
fruit that has the power to use emotions
of lust or perversion to turn one into
stone Blackbeard with some crew members
as we discussed comes to Amazon Lily
saying that he's come for the pirate
empress and that he won't let the Navy
have her soon Blackbeard is confronted
with a pacifista it looks like a kid
mihawk but lunarian with silver hair
brown skin and black wings the pacifist
attacks with sword and easily cuts a
mountain like mihawk did with the
iceberg a marine Fort it definitely
shocks Blackbeard but Blackbeard seems
to deal with it nonetheless he blocks
his attack with Armament hockey and then
uses the dark dark fruits black hole
attack we next see Blackbeard holding
bull by the neck as we know while he's
holding her her powers are nullified at
this point we see that pirate Empress
boa has a bounty of 1.659 billion and
blackbeards is 3.996 billion almost
every Marine and blackberry pirate
around including Vasco and Devin has
been turned to stone Kobe is there
watching helplessly he wants Blackbeard
to release boa so she can return the
others back to normal but Blackbeard
doesn't trust her he's ready to kill her
and seemingly sacrifice Vasco and Devin
in the process but then Rayleigh The
Dark Knight and Goldie Rogers right hand
Man shows up Rayleigh offers to mediate
and Defuse The Situation Blackbeard
decides to agree to the terms and leaves
however Rayleigh says that it was only
the particulars of the situation which
made it possible to save boa since at
his age he couldn't have possibly one in
a head-to-head fight against Blackbeard
now this statement is huge praise for
Blackbeard because if anyone can see
strength and is strong himself even if
he's not in his prime anymore it's
Rayleigh so it seemed like finally
Blackbeard didn't get his way for once
but even that's debatable yes the
combined forces of boa Kobe the pacifist
doesn't really made him retreat but his
goal was also for the Navy not to get
their hands on bulla's fruit and now
that she's in rayleigh's hands he
probably feels like the Navy won't get
it beyond that he didn't come away
empty-handed in fact he used the
opportunity to kidnap Captain Kobe the
hero of the rocky Port incident now he
has a very valuable hostage like when he
had Ace and he even got his crew members
back but it doesn't stop there recently
we saw Blackbeard attacking law at his
crew he knew that one of them either a
law kid or Lou goofy would come this way
and was prepared to fight whoever came
he wants to take all of their world
pornoglyphs and so we have this fight
now set up between Blackbeard and law
but Blackbeard is obviously the heavy
favorite lost crew hasn't shown itself
to be that useful yet while Blackbeard's
is a crew of monsters with OP devil
fruits as we've seen throughout this
video it's very likely that this will
just be another win to add to
Blackbeard's list of accomplishments and
after he attacked boa and kidnapped Kobe
I feel like this Victory here against
someone with the same Bounty as Luffy at
3 billion berries will be more than
enough to propel his Bounty ahead of
shanks's bounty which is already really
close to Blackbeard's own and so that
covers Blackbeard and all of the known
members of the Blackbeard Pirates
obviously there's so much speculation
that can be done about Blackbeard about
why he has three skulls on his pirate
flag about his true ties to zebek about
why he can have more than one fruit
power and so on but that's not the topic
of this video for this one we just
covered what we know so far about
Blackbeard and his crew members and
their trajectory alone definitely makes
it clear that they'll be one of the
final antagonist that Luffy has to take
on in fact note how Blackbeard has 10
Titanic captains while Luffy said in the
beginning that he wanted to find 10 crew
members it's likely that in the end
Luffy will go up against Blackbeard and
he'll have each one of the 10 main Straw
Hat crew members fight one of the 10
Titanic captains and then we'll finally
see who will win the Sun or the darkness
although we probably all know that it
will be Luffy the Sun God and future
pirate king but nonetheless the Hal will
be very interesting now chill parking
with it and smash that like button until
you shut off the YouTube fireworks if
you enjoyed this video and want to keep
these longer one piece videos coming be
a smashing pirate king rather have Pasco
Orochi and the universe will reward you
accordingly let me know in the comments
if you'd like me to cover any other
Cruise in detail like this make this the
day you join the nakama by subscribing
and hitting that notification Bell to
turn on all notifications or you will
miss future one piece videos and updates
not to mention chapter reviews while you
wait for the next video to drop feel
free to check out my huge and growing
one piece playlist that includes videos
on the yonko all Admirals all zones and
much more link to that is in the
description on screen now thanks again
for watching if you made it all the way
to the end drop a praise the sun in the
comments to let me know and to support
Luffy at the same time the sun god and
until next time see you Space Cowboys